on va tout arrêter au bout de quelques
semaines à peu près deux mois on va voir
le docteur émirats bazin l'aurait
explique que la rémission complète de
diabète est possible dans certains cas
qu'elle passe par un repos forcé et une
remise à niveau du panthéon
on avait observé dans d'autres formes de
traitements comme par exemple les gens
l'aval de chirurgie bariatrique que
quand on réduit le travail du pancréas
dans les chirurgies en réduisant
énormément l'apport de calories dans
notre approche à nous en le réduisant
d'une façon plus modeste mais un des
médicaments qui vont le soutenir un peu
comme au temps avec quelqu'un qui nous
poussait dans le doubs en vélo mais le
vent dans le dos on regarde
effectivement qu'on arrive à de repartir
sur de meilleures bases
l'émission et diabète dans la même
phrase voilà un concept nouveau inconnu
il y a dix ans et la nouvelle arrive à
point l'épidémie est mondiale et la
situation est encore plus grave au sein
de la population canadienne
de 1980 à 2014 on est pincé sur la
planète en l'espace d'une seule
génération de 100 millions à 422
millions d'adultes souffrent souvent
sans savoir de diabète soit un humain
adulte sur 13
la proportion de la population mondiale
touchés par cette affection a ainsi
presque doublé au canada tout un jeu
confondues c'est maintenant un citoyen
sur 4 ou 25 % des canadiens plus de 8
millions d'entre nous donc sur une
population de 35 millions qui sommes
diabétiques ou bris diabétiques mesurer
votre tour de taille parce que ce serait
beaucoup plus important que votre poids
corporel comme acteur daggett pour un
fait mal a dit le docteur jean pierre
després et directeur scientifique de la
chaîne internationale sur le risque
cardiométabolique de l'université laval
dans la ville de québec on parle encore
beaucoup de poids poids santé
et moi comme sheikh charles si je vous
emmène dans mon univers tu as maintenant
25 ans que le droit interne celui qu'on
finale et pas nécessairement sous la
peau battu le plus dangereux pour la
santé du coeur et maintenant pour la
santé du cerveau
le diabète un certain nombre de maladies
chroniques il ya plus d'une vingtaine
d'années matelas on avait proposé un
club à la mesure du tour de taille nous
permettait de plus parmi les gens qui
sont en surpoids ou qui sont abattues
qui sont les plus actifs
les études montrent qu à long terme si
on fait me dit comme ça pas de manière
voilée tendu mais pendant une période
limitée il n'y a pas d'effets à long
terme sur la santé
donc il n'y a pas de danger majeur c'est
après son retravaille on reprend nos
muscles et tout récemment le physicien
québécois normand mousseau professeur de
physique bien connu ici a affirmé s'être
guiry du diabète en suivant un régime
extrêmement strictes il a fait part de
son expérience dans un livre nouveau
comment se débarrasser du diabète de
type 2 sans chirurgie ni médicament
pendant longtemps on entend on s'est
vraiment contentés simplement de
regarder cinq tombes
quand on regarde quelle est l'origine on
s'aperçoit que l'origine c'est le
surpoids et ça c'est pas une surprise de
tout le monde le savait mais c'est
vraiment la graisse abdominale la
grèce.vers en effet en priorité à
l'intérêt des organes afin des les plus
accessibles quoi que ce soit et donc il
peut suivre que très rapidement les
organes donc se débarrasse pas du tout
la grève sauf à 10 par ailleurs une
partie la grèce qui doit rester mais
disparaît en partie est l'organe reprend
le pancréas reprend sans fonction entre
la chirurgie extrême de l'estomac et la
diète sévère que peu des diabétiques
arrive vraiment à suivre l'équipe du
docteur émirats basse alors est temps
donc elle d'ouvrir une troisième voie
celle de la rémission par un repos forcé
et une remise à niveau du pancréas on
avait à peu près 40% des gens avec la
proche qu'on avait avait pas eu besoin
de reprendre aucun médicament
après deux ans mais en gardant un mode
de vie le plus optimale possible
ici on est sur une échelle de plusieurs
centaines de patients pour confirmer
donc je pense qu'on a besoin d'à peu
près 2 ans pour confirmer la proche
après ça il faut qu'elle ait confirmé et
sous réserve que les autorités de santé
endosse ce genre d'approché mais droit
dans ce cadre là toutes les ai toutes
les ingrédients sont déjà disponibles un
reportage de radio canada international